>> Juan: WELCOME BACK.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE HAS
CONTROL OF THE BORDER CRISIS AND
BLASTING THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
CONDITIONS LEADING TO THE SURGE
OF MIGRANTS.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, 170,000 PEOPLE
APPREHENDED AT THE BORDER, A
20-YEAR RECORD.
THERE'S 22,000 UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
THAT'S A RECORD.
THAT SOUNDS TO MOST FOLKS LIKE A
CRISIS.
>> LOOK, IT'S WAY DOWN NOW.
WE NOW HAVE GOTTEN CONTROL.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAVE -- THEY
DIDN'T PLAN FOR, WHICH COMES
EVERY YEAR, THIS FLOW, WHETHER
IT'S 22,000 OR 10,000, THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE BEDS THAT WERE
AVAILABLE.
THEY DIDN'T PLAN FOR THE
OVERFLOW.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMENTS COME AS WE LEARN OF A
SICKENING STORY OF POSSIBLE
HUMAN SMUGGLING.
POLICE INVESTIGATING A CASE IN
HOUSTON, TEXAS WHERE MORE THAN
90 PEOPLE WERE DISCOVERED PACKED
INSIDE A HOME.
THE ASSISTANT POLICE CHIEF
GIVING US MORE DETAILS.
>> OUR SWAT TEAM WENT IN AND
EXECUTE THE SEARCH WARRANT.
WHEN THEY GOT IN THE HOUSE, THEY
REALIZED THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING
TO TURN INTO A SMUGGLING, HUMAN
SMUGGLING INVESTIGATION.
WE REALIZED THERE WERE OVER 90
PEOPLE INSIDE.
THERE'S CONCERNS THAT THERE MAY
BE SOME POSITIVE COVID CASES IN
THE HOUSE.
>> Juan: KATIE, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS SO UPSETTING.
HUMAN SMUGGLING IN HOUSTON AS
TRAGIC AS IT MIGHT BE IS NOTHING
NEW.
I SAW TODAY 2019, IN TEXAS, MORE
THAN 1,000 PEOPLE FREED FROM
HUMAN SMUGGLERS.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT IMMIGRATION
REFORM MIGHT LESSEN THE PRESSURE
THAT PEOPLE WOULD WANT TO EVEN
PUT THEMSELVES, THEIR CHILDREN
IN THE HANDS OF SMUGGLERS?
>> Katie: NO, ACTUALLY.
ANY KIND OF AMNESTY OR
IMMIGRATION REFORM AT THIS POINT
WOULD CONTINUE THIS MASSIVE FLOW
OF PEOPLE IN TO THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T STOPPED THE
FLOW.
SO IF YOU'RE GIVING INCENTIVES
TO COME TO THE COUNTRY AND
REWARDING PEOPLE FOR BREAKING
THE LAW AND COMING HERE
ILLEGALLY WITHOUT A MECHANISM TO
STOP THEM AT THE BORDER OR
TURNING THEM AWAY, YOU'RE ONLY
CREATING ANOTHER CRISIS IN THE
FUTURE.
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT THE
DREAMERS FOR DECADES NOW.
REALLY?
WE HEARD ABOUT DACA RECIPIENTS
FOR YEARS ON END.
RIGHT NOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS CREATING A NEW
GENERATION OF DACA RECIPIENTS
WHILE THEY REFUSE TO STOP THE
FLOW OF PEOPLE COMING IN THE
COUNTRY.
THEY'RE CREATING A CRISIS DOWN
THE ROAD.
DEMOCRATS SAID THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN BORDER SECURITY.
TODAY THE PENTAGON SAID THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO CONTINUE BUILDING
ANY PART OF THE BOARDER WALL AND
TAKING BACK THE FUNDING.
AND PIECES OF THE WALL THAT HAVE
BEEN PAID FOR ARE SITTING IN
LOTS AND ROTTING.
THAT DON'T HELP.
I DON'T THINK THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS ANY INTENTION
TO STOP THE FLOW INTO THE
COUNTRY.
>> Juan: SO JESSE, THE PRESIDENT
OF COURSE IN HIS SPEECH TO THE
CONGRESS THIS WEEK ASKED
CONGRESS TO ACT.
HE SAID SPECIFICALLY, SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN AGREE ON AS THE
DREAMERS.
DO YOU THINK CONGRESS CAN DO
MORE THAN JUST TAKE SELFIES AT
THE BORDER?
>> Jesse: NO.
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN DOESN'T WANT
TO SOLVE THE CRISIS.
HE'S DOING WHAT HIS DONORS WANT.
THEY WANT TO OPEN BORDERS
BECAUSE THEY BENEFIT FROM THE
CHEAP LABOR AND THE CHEAP LABOR
CRUSHES THEIR COMPETITION, WHICH
IS SMALL BUSINESS.
I'LL EXPLAIN HOW, JUAN.
SAY YOU'RE REMODELLING YOUR
BATHROOM.
YOU CAN HIRE AN AMERICAN
COMPANY, MOM AND POP CONTRACTOR,
BEN HERE FOR GENERATIONS.
THEY PAY INSURANCE, THEY HAVE
THEIR LICENSES.
THEY PAY THEIR WORKERS A FAIR
WAGE.
AND THEY PAY TAXES.
THEY'LL GIVE YOU A QUOTE FOR
$10,000.
MAYBE WORD OF MOUTH YOU HEAR
ABOUT AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
NO INSURANCE, NO LICENSES.
HE HAS A TEAM OF HARD WORKING
GUYS FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
THEY DON'T PAY ANY TAXES.
HE WILL PROBABLY GIVE YOU A
QUOTE $5,000 CASH.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
YOU GOING TO PAY THE GUY $5,000
CASH?
NAIL DO THE SAME JOB.
THEY'LL TAKE THE MONEY.
WON'T PAY ANY TAXES AND PROPERLY
WIRE 75% BACK HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES IN GUATEMALA.
WHAT DOES THAT DO TO THE
AMERICAN WORKERS, JUAN?
IT DEPRESSES WAGES, TAKES AWAY
THEIR JOBS.
IT SENDS MONEY OVERSEAS.
AND WE GET LESS TAX RECEIPTS
THAT WE CAN SPEND ON AMERICANS.
HOW DOES THAT HELP THE AMERICAN
WORKER?
IT DOESN'T.
>> Juan: I AGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK THAT'S A REASON FOR
REFORM.
>> Jesse: YOU AGREE.
I'M GLAD YOU AGREE.
>> Juan: I AGREE.
THAT'S A REASON FOR IMMIGRATION
REFORM TO GET MORE IMMIGRANTS IN
TO THE TAX SYSTEM.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT WAS HECKLED
IN ATLANTA BY PEOPLE CALLING FOR
AN END TO ICE AND END TO THE
DETENTION OF IMMIGRANTS.
SEEMS LIKE HE'S GETTING PRESSURE
FROM ALL SIDE.
>> Greg: I CAN USE THE DEMOCRAT
SLOGAN "IT'S NOTHING NEW."
HEY, LOOK, THERE'S A HOUSE WITH
90 PEOPLE IN 900 SQUARE FEET.
HEY, THAT'S NOTHING NEW.
A SPIKE IN CRIME?
NOTHING NEW.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET MAD
ABOUT THE FORCED LABOR, ABUSE OF
CHILDREN, TRAFFICKING, TAKE A
PAGE OUT OF BIDEN'S BOOK.
IT'S THE LACK OF MASK AND LACK
OF SOCIAL DISTANCING IN THAT
HOUSE OF 90 PEOPLE THAT YOU
SHOULD BE TRULY OUTRAGED ABOUT.
>> Juan: TUCKER, A QUESTION FOR
YOU.
>> Greg: UN-AMERICAN.
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
BIDEN SAYING THE SHELF WAS
BIGGER WHEN I GOT HERE.
NOT ENOUGH STAFF, NOT ENOUGH
PEOPLE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> Tucker: LOOK, THIS IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR AN ATTACK ON
DEMOCRACY, THIS IS IT.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS OF THE PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER OR THE CHILDREN IN CAGES.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
MOST IMMIGRATION AT THIS POINT
IS HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT STACKING
THE ELECTORATE.
IMMIGRATION REFORM, THE REAGAN
AMNESTY OF 86 LED TO A MASSIVE
FLOOD OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE WHO VOTES SO
THEY WIN.
THEY'RE DILUTING THE VOTES OF
AMERICANS OF ALL BACKGROUND AND
IT'S AN ATTACK O